bon renom veut qu'on est à la télé j'ai
de poser les questions à la con mais
vraiment des questions très con par
exemple tu préfères ton père et ta mère
ça commence bien jeu j'aime les deux les
deux m'ont préserver du froid de la fin
de l'ignorance tu préfères hitler ou
staline staline ah bon si j'ai le choix
entre la peste et le choléra temps
éclair il paraît qu'il aimait beaucoup
les animaux
tu dois partir à deux pendant trois ans
sur un vaisseau spatial choisir de
partir avec guy bedos anne sinclair ou
patrick bruel
combien d'années pour trois ans j'ai
perçu ce fan sinclair pour raisons
alimentaires non élémentaire t'aurais pu
prendre guy bedos pour faire du lest si
tu avais pas le choix je préférerais
faire l'amour avec une fille très très
laide ou avec un mec très très beau si
j'avais vraiment pas moi qui fais très
longs métrages une filtre à l'aide tu
préfèrerais très incarnée en michel
drucker jean-pierre foucault ou patrick
sabatier michel drucker sans hésitation
à qui trouve tu le plus de circonstances
atténuantes à infusion qui se tape des
petites ou un jeune qui tapent sans de
thiviers qui se tape des petites de quel
âge 12 ans un jeune qui tape sur les tu
rentres chez toi le soir qui étoffera le
plus peur dans noir mme ça le pen ou
tapis l'open mais c'est toujours pareil
entre la peste et le choléra
la peur de le pen doit membres
ton avis renault y at il une vie avant
la mort à bâle mais est ce qu'il ya une
vie avant sacrée soirée jeu pas sur lui
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un peu de
bleu